hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
trans women should be legally treated as
women tell me why you're strongly
disagreeing
because I'm a molecular geneticist
well I'm not even sure everybody else is
clapping okay so tell me tell me with
that because I'm not a I know I count on
my fingers I know nothing about jeans
being male or being female is a
developmental process you can't go
backwards
so you can't change your sex like you
cannot do that and the truth is that
currently in California prisons and
prisons in other parts of the country
women are getting impregnated
by other women
and there's just no way that maybe this
is against the U.N I
when after World War II there was like a
I don't remember what body came up with
this
statue but it was against I believe it
was the hey you cannot house female
prisoners with male prisoners because
they get raped
and that's happening today and it's not
in the news it's not in the common news
but I know about it so so that's the
argument for so you're I just want to
make sure I'm clear about this so your
argument is because you have
domain-specific expertise as a molecular
geneticist and then the legal component
of that is you're grounding that in your
experience of what a man is and what a
woman is yeah yeah I'm sorry I just this
bothers me so much well that's why we're
talking about it yeah I know I just my
heart pounds and I just
you know I go to the women's
I go to the women's
changing room at my gym and there's a
dude in there he's putting on makeup and
hoop earrings and this is not something
a woman does when she goes to work out
and yeah
well so I know nothing about what
happens in women's rooms
so uh so that's the behavior is not
common in women's rooms nor do women
beat each other to death but men do
you know and it's just it's so sad that
women have internalized misogyny to the
point where the man's Comfort is takes
precedence over the woman's safety
there's a reason why they don't want to
be in men prisons because men beat each
other to death women don't do that